dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana affair I
consider this one to be one of the most
influential papers in the field of light
transport normally to create a
photorealistic image we have to create a
digital copy of a scene and simulate the
paths of millions of light rays between
the camera and the light sources this is
a very laborious task that usually takes
from minutes to hours on a complex scene
noting that there are many well-known
corner cases that can take up to days as
well as the rays of light can bounce
around potentially indefinitely and if
we add that realistic materials and
detailed scene geometry descriptions are
not easy to handle mathematically it is
easy to see why this is a notoriously
difficult problem simulating light
transport in real time has been an
enduring problem and is still not solved
completely for every possible material
model and light transport effect however
voxel cone tracing is as good of a
solution as one can wish for at the
moment the original formulation of the
problem is continuous which means that
rays of light can bounce around in
infinitely many directions and the
entirety of this digital world is
considered to be a continuum if we look
at the mathematical formulation we see
infinities everywhere we look if you
would like to learn more about this I'm
holding a master level course at the
Technical University of Vienna the
entirety of which is available on
YouTube as always the link is available
in the video description for the more
curious fellow scholars out there if we
try to approximate this continuous
representation with tiny tiny cubes we
get a version of the problem that is
much less complex and easier to tackle
if we do this well we can make it
adaptive which means that these cubes
are smaller where there is a lot of
information so we don't lose out on many
details this data structure we call a
sparse voxel oak tree for such a
solution mathematicians like to say that
this technique works on a discretized
version of the continuous problem and
since we are solving a vastly simplified
version of the problem the question is
always whether this way we can remain
true to the original solution
and the results show beauty unlike
anything we've seen in computer game
graphics just look at this absolutely
amazing footage I scream for my eyes and
all this runs in real-time on your
consumer graphics card imagine this in
the virtual reality applications of the
future my goodness I've chosen the
absolute best profession also this
technique Maps really well to the
graphical card and is already
implemented in Unreal Engine 4 and
NVIDIA has a framework game works where
they are experimenting with this in
their project by the name VX GI I had a
very pleasant visit at Nvidia's game
works lab in Switzerland not so long ago
friendly greetings to all the great and
fun people in the team some kinks still
have to be worked out for instance there
are still issues with light leaking
through thin objects beyond that the
implementation of this algorithm
contains a multitude of tiny little
distinct elements it is indeed true that
many of the elements are puzzle pieces
that are interchangeable and can be
implemented in a number of different
ways and that's likely one of the
reasons why and Vidya and others are
still preparing their implementation for
widespread industry use soon we'll be
able to solidify the details some more
and see what the best practices are I
cannot wait to see this technique appear
in the video games of the future note
that this and future episodes will be
available in 4k resolution for a
significant bump in the visual quality
of the series it takes a ton of
resources to produce these videos but
it's now possible through the support of
you fellow scholars on patreon there's a
more detailed write-up on that I've
included it in the video description
thank you so much for supporting the
show throughout 2016 and looking forward
to continuing our journey together in
2017 thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]